a clear message from kiev to moscow at a
rally where thousands of people urge
ukraine's government to stand up to
russia
some here fought for ukraine veterans of
the country's war with russian-backed
separatists in the east and they say
they'll fight again
we are ready we are ready to fight if it
happens we don't want to but it will
happen we are here to stay this kind of
meeting is about ukrainian people uh to
get gather all i want together to show
that we are not separated we love our
country and we also
can protect it if it needed in any time
so that's why we are here some
demonstrators gathered beneath a statue
of taras chevchenko a 19th century poet
and artist a symbol of ukrainian
national pride
as moscow continues to build up its
military hardware and forces on
ukraine's border some western
intelligence officials say kiev could be
a target
washington says that russia could attack
ukraine at any moment the kremlin says
it has no plans to invade but some
countries are taking no chances and
advising their citizens to leave the u.s
is evacuating its diplomats a difficult
situation for ukraine's president who
called for calm
the truth that we have different
information and now the best friend for
enemies that is panic in our country and
all this information that helps only for
panic
doesn't help us with so much conflicting
information most people here don't know
what to believe some say they've heard
it all before others are anxious but no
one wants another generation growing up
with another war
natasha butler al jazeera kiev